THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE UK, ENGLAND, AND
GREAT BRITAIN
The actual name of the sovereign state we
are talking about is The United Kingdom of
Great Britain and Northern Ireland (UK).
The United Kingdom is made up of the countries
England, Scotland, Wales, and Northern Ireland.
The confusion of the terms seems to revolve
around the term “country” and the political
powers that are perceived based on that word.
While the four countries that make up the
UK are considered separate in the minds of
locals, and in certain sporting events, their
powers for local law and control are devolved
from the UK.
Think of the 50 states of the United States,
while each state has their own set of laws,
they all are still under the power of the
federal government.
In the case of the UK, it is somewhat similar,
though certain responsibilities are also implied,
like healthcare and education, that are delegated
to three of the four countries.
The responsibilities that are delegated differ
from one country to the next.
England is the only country in which the UK
does not devolve any powers and instead it
is legislated directly by the UK government.
When it comes to international politics, it
is the sovereign nation of the UK that is
recognized and not any of the four constituent
countries.
The term “Great Britain” refers to the
land mass that comprises England, Scotland,
and Wales.
Something that aids in the confusion as to
the difference between Great Britain and the
UK is that the term is sometimes internationally
used as a synonym for the UK.
For instance, the UK’s Olympic team competes
under the name “Great Britain” and the
ISO (International Organization for Standardization)
gives the UK the country codes of GB and GBR.
This can be confusing given that the ISO also
codes England, Scotland, and Wales as subdivision
countries of the UK but Northern Ireland as
a subdivision province.
If you’re getting the impression that Northern
Ireland is the red-headed stepchild of the
UK, you may be right! (both figuratively and
literally, if you believe the current statistics
for redheaded populations that is)
The confusion over the definition of these
four countries, in reference to the UK, is
further muddied up in sporting competitions.
There are several international sporting events,
like the commonwealth games, and football
competitions, in which each of the four has
their own team, and do not compete under a
unified national team.
When competing under these conditions, their
nations are referred to as “home nations”.
Because each team is from a specific home
country, it can lead some to think these countries
have political autonomy as well.
Given the inebriated thought processes attained
during the enjoyment of these competitions,
it’s not too hard to understand where this
drunken confusion comes from.
If you’re curious when these unions between
the countries that comprise the UK came about,
it happened as follows: England and Wales
were joined in 1536.
Scotland and England were joined together
in 1707, along with the previously joined
Wales, to officially form the Kingdom of Great
Britain.
Ireland decided to join up in 1801, at which
point the United Kingdom of Great Britain
and Ireland was formed.
In 1922, however, many of the Southern counties
of Ireland decided to remove themselves from
the union and the UK changed their name to
the United Kingdom of Great Britain and Northern
Ireland.
So in summary:
Great Britain = England, Scotland, and Wales
UK = England, Scotland, Wales, and Northern
Ireland (and the full name is the “United
Kingdom of Great Britain and Northern Ireland”)
England = Just the part of the island that
is England